unorthodox as it was
your parents were giving you an
education that you didn't want it's like
it would buckle up [ __ ] because
here you're going to dark out at six
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola With Me George Lopez let's do the
show because I got a lot of things to do
a thing I gotta go to that dry cleaners
you know George is oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Robert George Lopez oh my God OMG
together baby dude but didn't we know
each other in Chicago no with Jimmy Dore
no I might have known yeah we might have
done a show or two there but in Chicago
we were [ __ ] did we go out with that
lady that one time we drank Las Vegas
was that you with me and you yeah see
we're gonna have to know that story yeah
uh Glory oh [ __ ] night I remember
Vegas do you remember what I was doing I
went downstairs to go buy some candy and
then I ran into somebody man you or
somebody then the girl that's that
blonde lady yeah that tall blonde yeah
yeah
and we I I
can we say can we talk about this can we
talk about this I don't even [ __ ]
hardly remember
but I do remember but I don't remember I
mean I remember and we can tell this
with the show I remember we got so lit
they go
hi I'm Graham by the way hi Graham Gil
Crew Please
we knew each other in Chicago dude yeah
John DeVos yes yes or yes and at the
funny firm yes we worked together at the
funny person that's right and then I
moved out here in 95.
and then I started seeing you on TV and
I was like look at [ __ ] Graham and I
was like [ __ ] hey man you know what
man like that's you know I mean this
this was a different time so many people
you saw on TV you didn't like it was
[ __ ] finally going to see a guy up
there that you didn't mind look at Chase
that [ __ ] Channel he was you were
yeah you were [ __ ] amazing man and
it's funny man cause like you don't see
anybody and you don't know where they
are like I I think of it like this is
the thing that pops in my head I think
comedians
and you know we'll talk about all that
but a little bit like a Kino ball in
that big thing that the balls are just
bouncing around huh yeah and then
eventually one gets sucked up to the top
right but it could be me could be Graham
it could be somebody else and it doesn't
mean that that numbers is gonna hit that
number could just be a pilot it could be
a script order it could be a [ __ ]
holding deal could be a development deal
You Could Be Your Own Worst Enemy
and then you get once you get really one
it's almost like in fighting where the
dude says hit me with your [ __ ] best
shot because if you don't
he's gonna [ __ ] you up yeah so you got
to make that punch last you got to make
it count yeah you can't be like give me
your best shot all right she's like
that's it you know what I mean so you
got one [ __ ] and this and it's [ __ ]
hard man yeah you see a guy all [ __ ]
hammered a bit man what do we end up
doing where do we end up going I
remember Crazy Horse we were in Vegas so
the first time I knew you in Chicago but
we never worked together and we're
around guys we were on the same guys
same guys in Chicago funny firm because
I worked that club yep I love the funny
film which was an awesome room so so
Lynn the guy that ran the funny firm
classic club owner was he you only saw
when it was time to get paid or I did
you did you he paid you in person yeah
and then you went upstairs and then
there was a door
and you had to knock and they would
check and see who it was I think maybe
he buzzed you in and he had he was
sitting behind a desk with a pile of
money on the oh yeah and it was we were
done for the night call each guy up
right yeah and you go in there and what
would he do he'd just say like you did
great yeah maybe there's a bump or a
bonus or whatever but that was also 90
so almost all the business with cash so
these clubs would have you know 10 grand
in cash or whatever just sitting there
I'm gonna go out on a limb and say that
you guys prefer that
is that true I wasn't stupid enough to
steal back then yeah because I needed
every dollar I wasn't trying to hide
anything yeah I I I I yeah I mean I
liked it if I remember we but Len men
had a little bit of a gambling problem
and that was part of the reason the
business is that what it was oh yeah
it's too bad yeah because it was a great
Club not there anymore Club no it's a
Quiznos yeah 400 seat Club
Bill Hicks I saw Bill Hicks there I saw
Bill Hicks there I was in the back of
the room watching Bill Hicks was he on a
weekend like it was full oh it was
packed yeah he was packed and it was um
and I was there with Jimmy Dore
and uh we were like in all watching
Hicks and he just went on this rant he
was just just cutting everyone up and
then and then he goes any questions
and Dennis Leary had just popped
and Jimmy Dorr goes what about Dennis
Leary and Hicks goes well it's good to
see my act from three years ago still
working that's a dead that's a stone
cold quote from kicks he said that and I
was like we were all like did he just
and again this is before social media
right that would have gone viral now
and you know people a lot of people
don't know who Bill Hicks is but
if you're a fan of Comedy
there should be a Bill Hicks podcast
all things
atbh
all things Bill Hicks this [ __ ]
was Dynamic courageous never smoked like
a [ __ ] a chimney never raised
his voice High
and I remember he was there and I saw
him on a Wednesday night when there was
nobody there
and he did the same act as if there was
400 people there and to see him in a
club at any time and I remember he would
simmer he said that that
religious people would yell at him and
they would say you're a [ __ ] not
Fighters man this thing and he would say
like Christ
forgive me
that's great [ __ ] beautiful match
yeah you called out the first Gulf War I
mean he was like he was calling out the
first Gulf War and he took a lot of heat
here and then he went to England
and he blew kind of blew up in England
yeah oh wow it was he's a Fearless I
mean oh God there's there's no dudes I
don't think there's any guys like that
working right now because
you might not have known who he was
because he did a letterman I mean you
don't want to know when you're a great
[ __ ] comedian when you do a letterman
that never airs because it's true the
true edgy to air wow like they they they
it was about abortion about religion and
he was done and people went crazy and
they and CB is like well that will never
see the light of day so I hope you
enjoyed it because this is Never Gonna
air that's something I would love to see
out of a vault like that set that they
banned and that's pardon they aired it
right when he passed okay oh cool we
should show it we should we should show
it we should watch it and show it well I
was thinking we should actually just
start all things Bill Hicks because it's
already all things comedy so I just feel
like it's the already I think the
umbrella is there for it and uh what did
he hang with Matt does he was he with
anyone well he came out of Texas so he
came out of like Houston and those guys
yeah he came up with those guys that
wouldn't be hug Higgins and I believe so
yeah there was a bunch of Houston guys
Sam Kinison did you ever see Sam
Kingston live no never saw him live
so those guys there was a good Houston
thing going on in Houston with comedy
and uh you know Bill hicks's brother I
mean uh Sam kinison's brother and those
guys all came out of there yeah and it
was almost like you know San Francisco
had absolutely great comedians yeah and
then you go to Houston and they got
their clubs and they got a [ __ ]
community and they got us comedians in
their City I think that's such a cool
thing when that happens because there'll
be a couple of really strong comics and
it just makes the whole scene and the
whole town everyone's like well
this guy's just throwing fastballs I
better you're in the back of the club
going I better bring it and Chicago was
like that when I was a young comic
because I saw these older Comics that
were like prose and then you got to work
you know you got to hang out at the
funny firm and see guys like Hicks come
through town and all these guys that I
saw on TV and I think as a young comic
when you watch
like
I mean I saw emo Phillips I saw Judy
tenuta I saw
uh like Judy Gold I saw all these people
from TV
like MTV half hour Comedy Hour all those
shows that I was watching when I was in
college when I first started doing
stand-up when I was 18 and then I'm in
Chicago and they're just on stage and
it's just like boom boom boom and you're
sitting there going
I I mean I better bring this like yeah
yeah yeah so how did you how did you
decide to get into get into comedy when
you're 18. I knew at a young age I could
never have a real job I just knew it I
just couldn't my mom tells the story of
I said I'm never gonna have a job where
I gotta wear a suit
and then you know I was the class clown
yeah I played football in high school so
I was the funny you know the locker room
guys were you know my high school was 40
black so the the the talking smack was
big big and you had to bring it if you
showed any sort of weakness in the line
you know like so there was just a lot of
that and then what do they call it back
then uh what do they call it like how
could you like capping or cat they call
it capping or in my school they call it
ranking on each other like we used to
call it crawling on each other crumbing
on each other never heard that they'd
say are you [ __ ] crumming on me
[ __ ] I like that it sounds like
somebody's like eating over you all
right
that sucks how about the visual of that
one man it's like yeah hey man you're
[ __ ] criminal yo you're getting
crumbs all over me this sucks
pretty good I haven't said that and I
haven't thought of that in forever and
that's what it says hey that dude's
crumming on you hey [ __ ] matt'll be
crumbing on me who's coming on me right
get that [ __ ] off me man so so I think
you I think you learn
I mean I think you learn from people who
I think the African-American Community I
think and Latinos I think they're just
some funny ass people you've got that so
I had so I had the the African-American
community and then I was Irish Catholic
yeah and Chicago that helps too that's
[ __ ] it was like Irish Italian and
Jewish so it was like mob guys I knew
guys that dads were in the mob so the
the ball busting Chicago is just a it's
a slightly nicer New York it has that
nice Midwest charm but it's still like
everyone's kind of jabbing at you what
was the description what would you say
is that is that what you would call it
I I say cleaner New York but [ __ ] that I
mean the people are better in Chicago
it's a Midwestern New York it's still
because the thing is about Chicago it's
it's in some ways and this is a
compliment it's the just still the
biggest city in the midwest it still has
that Midwest charm your neighborhood bar
your neighborhood Diner and everyone's
like if you know a guy they'll bust your
balls if they don't know you but once
they know you then it's like you're my
guy you know what I mean and I got a guy
let me tell you my guy I show you your
guy and we'll get these guys together
and that's Chicago kind of like
everybody hangs out and knows each other
and you know I knew Chicago cops
um so you knew you knew Chicago mobsters
and Chicago cops you were kind of like
they're the same
time
it was just like you walk in a room it's
like there's Paulie there's Timmy
there's Mikey Mikey's a cop Timmy works
for the city Paulie's cities in
construction you know and you're like ah
they're all yeah when I was in high
school my sister dated a
a mob guy's son oh and we you know I
didn't quite get we had moved there from
from Wisconsin when I was like 11. so I
would still sort of Leave it to Beaver
and I was getting this like crash course
in the city and they were like I
remember we all went out come from
Wisconsin and you end up in Chicago
you're like leave it to Bieber and then
you go to Chicago yeah and it's like and
it's they got the L they got the trains
they got the [ __ ] neighborhoods and
you know what and this is this is the
80s so my parents were divorced my mom
was just like all right honey ride the
train were these kids riding the train
all through Chicago in the 80s there was
so my sister dated this guy and then and
and uh I wanted to get my hair cut like
his because he was older and his cool
eight you know 80s haircut so I went to
and I go into this barber shop now I
understand it was a mob shop and and
he's like oh you're Johnny's you're
Johnny's friend and they're gone and
they're being all nice and they're like
tell John I said hi which I now I
realize he's going I want the old man to
know I'm helping out his son's
girlfriend's right brother
two months after I got that haircut it
was a it was a it was in a um
a hotel in the in the suburbs two months
after that there was a mob hit in the
parking lot
yeah and who was it
I don't remember but it was like you
know one of those guys with the old
school nicknames like
Louis the lip yes Johnny two two you
know two Knuckles or whatever weasel yes
a weasel you know and they gunned him
down outside of a zeldorado Cadillac
with his Rose tinted glasses and all
that like it was it was because you
didn't tell Johnny that you got your
haircut by the barber you didn't make
good on that kid's haircut I was at
Rosemont when I first started to do
bigger places you know in Chicago I did
the Oriental Theater it was called the
Oriental that's not me saying something
inappropriate you're not describing
Oriental Theater and then I think I
did I don't think I did the Chicago
Theater but then I went
to and did Rosemont
and Outsiders and that's a great place
four thousand seats and the first time
the guy said hey you sold out a couple
shows you have to have you come back huh
we're in the parking lot he goes yeah
have you come back and I would love to
have you uh and he does this and his car
starts its way over there I go what the
[ __ ] is that he goes Chicago baby I turn
it on to make sure it doesn't [ __ ]
blow up oh my God turn around and let it
run before I get in turns it on from
Disney ago so we were talking here
because
he had to start his car over there so if
it did blow up it didn't I mean he knew
to keep a distance right starts it up
and that's the first time I ever I had
ever seen anybody with an automatic to
start their car because they could get
blown up yeah Rosemont
was created you gotta you got an
appointment you're looking at your watch
well it was ringing on my block
the uh so so
please take your blood pressure medicine
now I'm also getting a message that
beers are ready I want some beers I
think that's what Gill needs
so so so yeah so rosemont's a mob like
they set that town up what oh yeah yeah
I know there's well it has everything in
it has an arena has a stadium it has a a
a a a
um an Italian restaurant with the big
Rose the [ __ ] around the outside I
mean you're right you're right it is and
then it had
and then there was a field that looked
like a field and next time you go back
it's one of those comments like the
Grove and you're like wait a minute
yeah this was a field that's what the
Zanies in Rosemont is now they just
built there from yeah that's there you
go because I think the concrete the
business the parking that yeah why
haven't empty it was it was different
I've only been to Chicago once that's
when I went a couple of months ago yeah
and the cops were different than they
are out here I really enjoy they were
different like what they were closer
together their personality closer
Brotherhood they it was just a great
working group of people to be around for
cops yeah you know over here people are
after each other you know that yeah I
want this job there they were together
they were together yeah and it was it
was good it was a good feeling one of my
landlords was a Chicago cop uh and he
was the really nicest guy and I remember
one time I was coming up because there's
a two-story a too flat I'm coming up the
exposed staircase
and his name was Phil Greco and he's
just peering through his window and I go
hey Phil and he goes oh I didn't know
who you were at first Graham I was about
to blast you with my 38. oh [ __ ] I was
like oh okay that's Phil wow that's your
car I I used to do about that voice yeah
yeah that was good what was he wearing
like shorts and the T-shirt shorts and a
tank top it was a summer yeah he'd have
a tank top with the with maybe like a a
short sleeve shirt open it all right you
know he'd be like you know and again I
remember one time we were coming to get
the cable fixed or something and he and
I was like I had to get the cable guy in
the downstairs and he's like
we'll have my cable guy come by
[ __ ] a man that's right that's I mean
Chicago was uh I got a busted for a
drunken disorderly and I dropped his
name and they're like all right kid dog
you can't do that they hear that I I
don't know you know I went out to dinner
at this nice steakhouse that you had
been to before and uh I sat there there
was a return
semi-retired Lieutenant uh from Chicago
PD there and he was uh waiting to see
what his penalty was they tried to give
him 30 days on a bricks he said [ __ ] you
ain't taking your 30 days and he says
we'll we'll fight this one and he's like
got a lot of juice and he wanted us to
drink and I said well I don't want to
get all all [ __ ] up tonight I got to
fly out first thing in the morning like
you know I was coming back over here and
he said not a problem you wake up late
hey we can hold a plane up for you he
says Got Juice yeah that's juice
we can hold it up a little when I got
there
the somebody had the wrong time and the
cop that went there to pick me up
didn't see me get off the plane so they
sent somebody they sent a cop inside to
walk the plane to make sure that there
wasn't a mix-up that I got and so they
they took care of me and this guy
you know they don't do that here I've
never seen a cop walk the plane no he
went in walked the plane made sure I was
came in on a different flight the
lieutenant eventually I said well [ __ ]
he said where you at now I said well now
they've reduced it they want to give me
10 days and I got enough time to retire
if I [ __ ] one he was running a
security company on the site made more
money than was as a cop yeah and so he
just says I don't know what I'm going to
do yet he says I got I still got about
20 more days to make up my mind he said
I don't think they're either going to
let it all go or I just may walk
so I talked to my contact back in
Chicago last month and I I said and John
he says oh he walked he took the
retirement he didn't get anymore and
said goodbye now he's just doing the
security stuff making his bucks what
what does the you know you've seen the
1190 I know what the 1199 Foundation is
which is a great foundation for slain
officers the line of duty their families
and their children uh but what does
having the frame on your back license
mean because everybody's got it right
back in the day you probably could pay I
mean I shouldn't say it you could
probably donate uh some money and get a
frame and you saw them on higher end
cars so you go okay
there's somebody who said I know
somebody maybe Chief Gomez a cyber truck
or whatever I think it's a highway
patrol friend it's 11.99 is the Fun Day
11.99 Foundation of uh
and to get one of those when they pulled
you over and you saw the 11.99
the CHP officer would would
alleged maybe like hey man how's it
going who do you know maybe right who do
you know I know uh I knew uh Chief Gomez
back in the day and I didn't have I
didn't have a thing though but
does it work
I I don't know because I don't think it
works I never worked Patrol you know or
anything but do you think it works if
100 people are going to give you I I
think they're gonna give you know
they're gonna give you
a little bit of courtesy to find out hey
you know who are you what are you doing
here if they can realize within the
first few minutes hey that's just then
it's not gonna mean okay in comedy in
comedy like in police work like in
detective work like in the medical
profession like in any any business
there has to be an instinctual pulse
that says that's not good for me I'm not
going to go there I kind of go here you
know I don't think I'm going to do that
why not you're crazy ah that's not
doesn't feel like it's the right thing
for me
a friend of mine that was a higher
patrolman and he pulled a guy over and
as he was walking to the car something
inside of him said
go this way and don't go this way
and he looked at the guy the guy was
kind of like this right so whatever the
body language of the dude was he said
oh [ __ ] I'm I'm gonna go over here but
the guys looking he can't see over here
he's looking right here
and when he goes around the [ __ ] dude
had a a [ __ ] nine year this like like
this like he had his arm on the wheel
he's just like well and he saw that and
he said [ __ ] put your hands
we'll drop the gun [ __ ] this whatever
and he was he was gonna kill me like he
even said I was gonna kill you he said I
know
something told me to go around the one
but he gave himself away he was like
this he was like this and not like this
not a body language sure you got to be
able to see it you do you do and then
what they do uh when they stop you're by
yourself they put that Spotlight on
their mirror so they can't see me yeah
yeah yeah and but it's always better if
you're by yourself put that right there
and then walk around I think that was
during the day I think it was during the
day yeah
passenger side so they can't uh you have
a better perspective looking in
when you look across as opposed to right
you can't see right behind what's the
door what what's behind that door that's
why every cops ever told me and is both
hands on the wheel when you get pulled
over so they can see it's always sharp
it's always nice you can see my hands
the sheriff's department had uh as did
lab we had a frame that said kma 628
that was yeah that's that's the radio
response that was the frequency
for the radio the cops used so if you
had a license plate said kma 628 you
knew that you were related to something
some belonging to sheriff's department
chairman block used to say it's stupid
to put that damn thing on your plate
because then everybody anybody knows
anything about police work knows you're
a cop and you're a Target
and guys were using it to hope you know
if you have a little violation a lot
hoping that cop would sit there and say
ah he's a cop you know you know traffic
violation don't don't mess with it how
did you get your first talking about
that how did you get your first TV like
you moved out to so you did it there and
you moved where you moved here so I I
well I started in college and the first
time I ever did stand up there was a
college comedy competition that was
emceed by a guy uh in acid wash jeans
and a mullet named Judd Apatow and it
was it was it was it was amazing I was
18 I did it in college then I moved to
Chicago started doing it there saw Hicks
and everybody then I moved out here in
95 and just started working and where
did you live I lived in the valley I
lived in like North Hollywood you found
a place you came out here and found a
place or you were you I came up with two
two buddies two buddies of mine that
were like uh and we were in a sketch
comedy group as well they weren't really
they did some stand-up
um and we moved out and we so we found a
cheap apartment in North Hollywood my
share of the rent was something like 300
or something crazy like that you know
and uh and I sound like an old man gas
was a nickel
we grow our own shoes
[ __ ] a right but then um and then you
guys started just going to the clubs
like you go you go get the uh what that
thing was called that [ __ ] magazine
that had the all the things in the back
oh yeah the the the drama log yes yeah
that one I got that again
um backstage West backstage West you
know they're not one now the LA weekly
night has all the little massage Parts
looking for a guitar right here by the
sun Kim [ __ ] massage place in the
Guitar Center uh but but and then the
the giveaways they have those [ __ ]
candies that they only have it's almost
like a Kwa [ __ ] nothing
one of those candies like you're going
over there getting jacked up [ __ ]
Korean place look at that [ __ ] candy
with a [ __ ] Panda [ __ ]
regular store
dead giveaway they go that's why they
say you want to reach the candidate no
thanks try to give me a divorce
everybody know that's supposed to be go
wash your hands nobody was supposed to
be here but but uh you know so they they
they they give that [ __ ] away and also
in comedy like you're [ __ ] digging
for [ __ ] you know your final thing
you're dusted off you're like what is
this here you find your own trying to
find your own your own voice like what
what were the things that
that you that you gravitated you and
were the things were they the things
that when you were growing up that you
liked I mean I I definitely I I got on
stage as as often as I could we weren't
afraid I just I was like yeah I was
scared by yourself or with the sketch
person was well my so my parents were
theater people right my dad was like
there you go so I was on stage when I
was four I was in a play that my dad
directed I think or he was in they
needed some kid and they they always
tell the story I didn't want to go on
stage but they said but they gave me m
M's and as I got M M's I went on stage
and so my family I was the youngest of
four okay Charlie Chaplin
I just learned how to work my parents
for candy yeah but
but yeah were you afraid or anything man
I mean I was a little bit did you know
what you were gonna say or did it come
to you naturally uh you know we
performed a lot we would do plays you
don't want to understand them I I think
you and I because Gil said write me some
stuff and Momo said [ __ ] give it gets
off stage [ __ ] like he he he's
like [ __ ] uh Gia that model that oh
dude she loved the [ __ ] crowd like oh
hello
hi everyone I caught the Night Stalker
hello what are you doing whatever you
[ __ ] done today
uh so he you know there's things that
that I was [ __ ] scared to death like
I can't imagine being comfortable at an
age that you were young enough to
understand what you were doing even
which was it sounds like what you is
what you had I mean I was kind of scared
I was scared but I just I don't know I
loved it and I I there's a lot of things
I did a TV commercial when I was like
eight for like this Famous Footwear this
local shoe store did we find it if I had
it I would put that on my reel it's me
holding up a puma going I like these
like like it's the 70s man that's
awesome
um and you got it you went on an
audition and there was a bunch of kids
that you still remember I think so yeah
and
because you know over here they leave a
flyer in your car they go kids you were
thinking about getting into the acting
Community you show up that got you in a
[ __ ] back plate
the [ __ ] torn
yeah okay don't come back
well let me [ __ ] heal up and make a
decision then
but I mean it's like it's like you know
we [ __ ] suckers right they fall for
anything man Robert Powers never [ __ ]
[ __ ]
a [ __ ] it I'm Robert Powers acting
school sir I got to come on my shirt
I shouldn't even use his name because
it's a real dude oh yeah yeah that was a
real [ __ ] when you first moved to LA
you go wow you see bear [ __ ] you
they're looking for people they they're
so and and so somebody would see you and
go so tell me I'm new to La [ __ ]
already yeah all the other [ __ ] like
you got some money you came out here you
said well let's take him let's take his
money everyone comes at you those the
scientologists like everyone's trying
the Scientology come up to you yeah for
sure I was I was they should open a
comedy club and let's see how they can
yeah let's see if let's see how [ __ ]
how much Horrors the comedy Comics are
going there you know there'd be comics
and they're going hey man they let me
EMC I get free dinner you know what I
mean that's not so bad it's not so bad
they're pretty cool I mean they give me
freaking meter readings yeah do they I
mean
I got an audition when I first the first
year I was living in LA and I had this
agent who was like you know just sending
me on anything she'd always send me on
this like leading man [ __ ] so I'd go on
this you know I was in decent shape but
I go in these rooms these guys are
ripped I'm never gonna be that good
looking like come on I Go comedy submit
me for comedy [ __ ] right but she was
like we just got to get you on anything
so send me on all this stuff that I
wasn't would never get so she sent me to
something and it was at the celebrity
center do you think that do you think
that people like that this it just
occurred to me do you think that people
like that maybe get five dollars per
actor that shows up probably now now you
look at it right because somehow they
get the they get the the flyer and they
say you you bring us God we'll give you
five dollars a person when you settle up
I think that maybe that I wouldn't
they're not doing it for nothing I think
she later did she did get busted for
like doing Kickbacks on headshots or
something like that so that's right
because that's what they want they want
you they want then you get somebody and
then they say uh where's your headshot
oh I don't have a really show I got we
got a person yeah and then you're you
know so go ahead so what they say they
do this game you know I keep submitting
you but you're not getting called in I
think you need new headshots you know
maybe some acting classes and this guy
gives you a discount and you're like
this and they [ __ ] mecho right here
on your shoulder yeah
and what's this this is for Best Foods
I believe it was clam chowder but it's
hard to say it's hard to say so so what
do they submit you for so what did the
and they're like it's at the celebrity
center and I was like wait a minute I
was already which is a [ __ ] great
place by the way I mean outside yeah I
haven't gone in oh I haven't gone
because I'm I'm
you know I may be I might be homosexual
I don't know if I do kisses my neck I
think I'm I'm in like he's gonna grab
the [ __ ] potatoes
I don't know it's hard to say until
you've been in an accident you know how
your body's gonna react
but but the celebrity center
for for the property I drive by it every
day for the property of where it is
in Hollywood it had to have been uh a
master [ __ ] hotel back in the
Humphrey Bogart and everybody in there
because it's beautiful yeah
when you look on the outside and every
there's 200 [ __ ] windows and every
shade is drawn you're like that's
something's up yeah Too Many Shades John
something
and it's it's up but and it's not
it's not anything normal that we're used
to it's right right we're in California
the [ __ ] shades are down I was like
grown again living in Chicago and seeing
how things really worked
I was I was inherently cynical and and
I'm actually talking about this in in my
act that this I'm shooting especially
the end of October and I talk about my
parents took me to DACA when I was when
we were I was six we lived in Germany
wait a minute yeah I know
put your shoes on bring some tissue
here's M M's yeah every Eminem then
Eminem's your [ __ ] with some
peanut butter in the middle get over
here oh do a concentration camp kids wow
man
a whole thing in my act and it's it's
become the through line of the special
I'm going to shoot is is how I I had a
college professor dad and I was this
happened to me when I was six and so
it's made me very cynical I have a dark
view of the world and so at a very young
age so my dad had a research scholarship
he had a Fulbright and we were living in
Germany and wow and so and then the joke
I'm making my ACT is when you have a
college professor parents everything's
an educational experience right so we're
in Germany all we did was go to museums
and castles and I was like doesn't this
place have a goddamn water park or some
[ __ ]
a [ __ ] arcade
you walk through there oh yeah I'm
ducking everywhere because I went
through a castle Gil goes like this not
the guy that stay out here yeah [ __ ]
yeah I'll walk around the other side but
you know we can go I'll stay on this
side of the moon it's tiny here it is
yeah it's very tiny and then so we went
to my dad then took us to Dachau and you
know my sister was 14 my other sister
was 11. which is like okay those are
maybe the ages to start learning about
the world my brother was nine I think
that's too young I was six that's what
sixes you've only been in the world six
years one of the the most horrific thing
that's ever happened in the history of
the world like I'm six years old walking
around like there's the ovens there's
the you know yeah and so the shoes that
they have the defense and they have
photos up there showing Like This Is How
They Live you're walking through the
bunks and you know as a little kid I was
a sensitive kid I felt the energy of
that place and so I think I've always
felt that kind of energy so when you
know when I moved and then in Chicago
seeing like how the mob really ran
things and how you know how stuff was
really done you really do see how it is
right you see there's no joke you know I
like nobody gets into business doesn't
have an agenda yeah I mean when I was
when I was right out of college I was
waiting tables at a pizza place and the
cop would all the cops say for free
right and the delivery guys would park
in front of the pizza place it was a no
parking Zone and some every once in a
while the cop would put fake tickets
underneath those his Watch Commander
drove by it was just a whole scale
Chicago's just one big everybody's
greasing everybody's palm and that's
just how that City works I just assumed
that's how business is done when did
Cops start stop eating for free
when somebody when one of them bitched
about the food I I I don't know I I
remember one of my partners for years
you know he uh we call this medium well
right there Mario uh was the owner of
the Roxy and uh yeah okay so Mario's
Heather my old partner was walking a
foot beat in the rain and he says hey
come in out of the [ __ ] rain and so
he took him and he said you're hungry
says well yeah you know okay well games
he goes to papers what the [ __ ] are you
doing paying they don't pay back there
you know I need to come out here got all
his he was a Bag Man back there for the
judge he got all that money turned it
into positive stuff run and started
wrote in a busy the Roxy in the rainbow
were right actually he owned both of
them still there yeah and then he opened
one in in Vegas well he you know that's
how he there was a rainbow in Vegas huh
yeah he explained to me how he met my
partner and my partner was taking me
down he says you [ __ ] cops out here
stupid back there nobody pays for
nothing you guys come out don't even
come out of the [ __ ] rain and you pay
so it wasn't like that out here you know
people that may listen to this if you
are coming to Los Angeles or if you live
in Los Angeles and you've never been to
that part of the strip The Viper Room is
going to be torn down and they're going
to put Apartments there I think so if
you've never been to the Viper Room go
to The Viper Room It's [ __ ] amazing
it's haunted so Momos are out there when
you're done with your [ __ ] uh second
lunch
and it's a great place to see music yeah
I took slash uh not to drop names
but but I took slash like in 2010 Ace
Frehley was there and uh at The Viper
Room and I think slash is always on my
talk show and I said let's go see him
man so I went to go pick slash up and we
went picked them up I drove them we
drove to Viper Room we get in there man
slash dry you know he's got the hair and
things you know his glasses and there's
a little guy that's a little
um uh fireman you know but it's a short
shorter fireman you go hey slash
remember me that slash is like nah like
you said [ __ ] nah remember when you
got T-Bone right here at the top he goes
yeah yeah in the Pathfinder he goes yeah
yeah he goes I'm the dude that climbed
in the sunroof and pulled out your
leather jacket whoa and slash goes ah
[ __ ] hey man thanks
and you know and I said you got hit you
got with that guy so you guys got T-Bone
he goes yeah yeah we got T-boned and the
thing is we were sober and the dude that
hit us was [ __ ] up they were sober and
they were going on Sunset the dude was
coming up like Doheny and boom [ __ ]
rolled them they weren't a Pathfinder
wow that's crazy well since it's closing
let's all go with Slash let's go Ace
Freely looks like let's go let's go see
who's gonna be over there but they have
Monday nights where we're like dudes
just play you know different different
guys play but they're going to close it
down but if you haven't been to the
rainbow even to go eat or have lunch
remember [ __ ] around with like a hard
rock [ __ ] they still have the booth
where Led Zeppelin you can see the
pictures on the walls where Led Zeppelin
used to sit where kiss all Elton John
all those [ __ ] were in there I
came out today when I was in college I
went to college University of Arizona
and for my first time in LA and my
buddy's uncle is like we got to go to
the rainbow and we're going to the
rainbow and I see all these producers
with young girls and then at this booth
I'm not making this up I don't say it
like that have some I'm a producer God
damn it
I was like amen
we'll leave that in Aaron
go ahead go ahead and in the booth was
um Billy Joel and um Axel Rose sitting
next to each other having a conversation
there was and I was like
I couldn't and they were talking shop
and I was like as because I was like you
know I was 19 or whatever so I thought
oh there they won't get along they're
different genres of music no man they're
just me Pro musicians Talking Shop it
was awesome how did it look what were
they what were they wearing they looked
they were on brand I mean Joe was nice
suit the dark under his eyes like an
Uncle Fester that's to play the piano I
mean lean I mean just this is like 89 or
something like that an axel full axle
headband
like he's in axle gear that he was just
yelling the whole time
he just looked at me and I ran out no
but that but that place is historic the
rainbow and The Rock sea where they did
Up in Smoke Cheech and Chong did that
that they found me Mario even took me
upstairs where only it was a private
room upstairs where they used to go do
their business up so they got their dick
sucked everywhere they're not just
upstairs
oh yeah
they are a lot of stories you just tells
a lot of stories yeah dude Mario what he
didn't have a last name Italian it was
an Italian last name he was married to
the same lady for years I think little
Adler owns it who owns the rainbow and
the Roxy right now I think it's in Lou
Adler's family like uh you know Italian
I think Lou but so so so it was he was
just yeah he was a good guy yeah and he
passed away a few years ago and then but
he before he left he opened up another
place in Vegas did you ever meet Bill
gazari no because the gazaris is like
the early club now or whatever that was
okay and Bill gazari man they said have
like wet t-shirt contests and [ __ ]
longest pubes [ __ ] contests over
there girls
[ __ ] wild [ __ ] over there man because
sorry and and if you look up Bill ery
and you look at me I was more this hat
look just like a mobster he dressed like
a [ __ ] mobster in a [ __ ] tuxedo
with a thing and the hat hey I'm Bill
gazari and all the like you know all the
chicks were nice to him yeah yeah
because Bill gazar but Van Halen the
doors uh all those bands The Beach Boys
the turtles all those all the bands of
bands he had to play with stories that's
right yeah the whiskey she had the
whiskey on the corner
then you had gazaris and then you had
the Roxy the rainbow Van Halen all of
the bands all the bands that's awesome
and the Starwood on Crescent Heights in
Santa Monica which is not there anymore
it's a Russian yeah that was all on yeah
out of my league you know that was all
on the west side yeah
but but uh I mean people come here to go
visit some you know places where you
know the hot the Walk of Fame of course
you know but they're not there go to eat
in a place where you can see a picture
that Jimmy Page and the guys in Led
Zeppelin were there with 11 year olds
they used to go eat and have dinner so
that's right
there that's right I know do Adler all
right get them in they're on the Roxy
okay this is something that I always
thought about and it's funny how this
works out on the way over here I was
driving over
uh and I thought I don't think I'm gonna
do another special because what's in it
for me like what you know but I think I
would do one if I could do it at the
Roxy
um
put that out there yes that would be
badass yes okay so Lou I'm gonna call
you yeah someone forget about listening
uh I'm gonna call Lou Adler and I'm
gonna ask if I can do a special at the
Roxy and then have the after party at
the rainbow hell yeah and have a
dispenser at every table so underneath
dude that would be a great special
especially if you told a bunch of funny
stories about baltication oh the strip
yeah like it's an it's like a it's like
an homage to that I think you sit at the
rainbow and whole court and and then
walk over and do the special yes and you
could intercut between that if you
wanted to you tell store and then oh
dude that's I love I love that yeah
halfway through slow-mo shot of you
walking walking across the rainbow and
just cool ass music George Lopez Sunset
history I don't know son hey good place
don't take the pen that's a long name
yeah
your VIP passes they put a sticker on
you that's white mine
do you think I was the one that was
[ __ ] interested in here so so go
ahead so you go so after you know the
DACA on the Chicago thing so when I
moved here I was like that's a cult I
was just like Scientology I was like bam
that's I don't trust that at all but
also but also as as
um what they call it as unorthodox as it
was
your parents were giving you an
education that you didn't want it's like
it would buckle up [ __ ] because
here you're going to.com at six so I'm
sure up until they split everything had
a thematic you're gonna go here we're
gonna go here we're gonna go there we're
gonna go there and then uh so get ahead
but but right I would say that
everything that they were trying to do
to you were trying to make you guys
worldly they made me very I like I
understood the World by the time I was
about 19 20 years old I was like oh I
get yeah I get this stuff much much more
secure than a normal 18 or 19 year yeah
did some regular Suburban College kid
would have never right never had that
guy right because when I went to college
at University of Arizona I I was hanging
out with guys they grew up in mainly
white suburbs or whatever and they had
no clue and I was like oh no I go that's
a mob joint and they go what I go that's
a mob giant you guys are naive yeah I go
walk in there's a bunch of guys in
jumpsuits in the middle of the day like
what are you talking about it's a mob
giant you know or like why would they
all be at the salon guys
those guys have manicured hands there's
a reason for that yeah no but it's true
it's true it's true you see that stuff
so when I came here I was like
Scientology it's it's it's and and I you
know I had people come out I had like oh
you know I'm I'm young here where would
they see you like on the street or you
know I had some acting class or
something like that or yeah yeah yeah
I'm sure party I'm sure they have uh
Satellites with calm oh yes exactly
little birds uh where they go to parties
and they go to comedy clubs they go to
things and say if you're on stage and
somebody's in there goes hey I just
moved off in Chicago and then they're
like okay you know oh yeah they got the
rate they got the radar out there yeah
and so then like I said on this audition
and I was like all right I'm going to
this but there this I know this is going
to be great and the audition was just
weird the building was weird the the way
and I was like so and the the copy was
like weird I was like this is I mean
I've read some dumb [ __ ] before but this
was like yeah yeah
and I said so is this for Scientology
they're like oh it's just sort of an
educational video kind of a thing and a
movie and you know then they kind of
then they started dangling the like but
you know what but that that's a uh
that's a move yeah that that's a
grooming thing yeah right let's say
alleged can we put a Ledge in there you
know if I don't say it later because it
is now that you look at it from like
that right it's a it's a it's a [ __ ]
sure I mean it's a
it's a method that they have yeah
they're fishing yeah they're fishing
definitely and and
even I wasn't I'm way more Savvy now
like I have a friend of mine who was a a
cop with Phoenix PD for 24 years and he
was a child crimes investigator and I've
had him on my podcast a couple of times
to talk about like Epstein and stuff and
now it really it makes me it can it
makes even more sense just all the stuff
they're doing but they just had all of
this and then I saw like oh it's it cost
twenty five hundred dollars to get clear
or whatever and I was like oh God I was
like I was raised Catholic I know about
scam religions for money like come on
yeah yeah you know like come on how come
Jesus is wearing a bracelet
is suffering it's like that Carlin bit
like Jesus you know God loves you but
he's short of cash you know like that's
awesome it's Carlin's bit so I was like
I was like I was skeptical and then I A
friend of mine
you know I always try to do like
volunteer be of service right and and I
was like oh we're going to read to Inner
City kids this is like a year or two
after that audition I was like oh cool
we're reading it's cool we're helping I
was like I felt like you know I was I
was I was blessed that I had parents
that paid for my college you know and
even though they took me to dacao I
still like yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm sorry you had no choice either so so
you just want you yeah it's what it is
so I was like I got I you know I was
born with some privilege I got to give
back and yeah I did this for a couple
weeks maybe even a month or so and then
at this Reading Center
there was this one book and there was
this like other library and I was like
is that is elrond Hubbard the author of
those books and like yeah and I go so is
this affiliate anyway with Scientology
well and they gave me a flim flammy
answer and I was like oh you couldn't
give me a direct you didn't say no it's
not they donated the books yes they just
said well we in some conjunction with
this but not and I was like yeah you
can't like maybe be with Scientology
yeah you're kind of like with it or not
is this a drug cartel business well it's
sort of a world
entirely I probably
you can't really be certain about
anything these days you're more of an
export business yeah yeah yeah yeah
I mean export I mean we exported in our
asses but it still gets there it's still
trans just like Amazon ships
yeah it's like again my sister
boyfriend's dad I remember you know I
remember asking him before I knew I was
didn't know yet about like Mom I said
what do you what are you for living I'm
in a construction business like I
remember that I remember we all went out
to dinner at an Italian restaurant and
there never dropped a check
because there's a little kid I remember
my dad's arguing for the check yeah yeah
yeah yeah there was no check drop and I
remember the older brothers had to go
talk about a thing
I remember all of this stuff
you know what I mean he's talking about
something and that was like and they had
the white collar shirts they all look
like guys from the movie Thief you know
and I was like so I after having all of
that indoctrination so when you when I'm
in the Scientology and I start getting
Flim Flam double talk I go okay so it's
uh this is a Scientology yeah same kind
of thing yeah yeah and and you know it's
they're still out there I mean they're
they're because of social media and all
the things they're harder to really kind
of find I think maybe uh tenure and the
early maybe late 2000s I went to uh the
Hilton and we went to I think we might
have been a day early and I'm like um is
there a place to get some Italian food
and the guy says you want Italian food
or do you want Italian food
oh my God I don't know better answer
correctly yeah yeah it's a little bit
it's a little bit further away I said
great so we went and I think it was in
Goodfellas I think I think where he
throws uh takes uh uh Sharon Stone down
the stairs in that bar with the red uh
end tables in the bar that he did that
one in casino and casino or Casino yes
when he's dragging her down the stairs
it's in that restaurant wow so there was
a guy in there I won't say his name uh
but it's his first his name started with
little before his name
that's and great I go there he meets
this great guy knows me great guy come
in eat we drink we laugh he sits down
with us I said I'm at the Hilton man hey
guys hey come hey God blessed but you
know unfortunately I'm not able to go in
any of the casinos so what do you mean
he goes yeah you know it's a little uh
what do you call it racketeering uh
charge I said well so what does that
mean uh you know uh all right I'll say
it you know
I can't go and gamble on a on anywhere
in the world I said what do you mean I
kind of ship on a paddle boat at a
[ __ ] church I can't go to I'm not
welcome in any casinos in the world wow
so you will be coming to the show Friday
I can't
he he loan sharking racketeering and
there's another maybe the RICO some [ __ ]
but he was banned from establishments
that had yeah even if you said I bet you
can't climb that ladder you couldn't
[ __ ] watch the guy climb the ladder
he couldn't be around any bedding
and I don't know what happened with him
man he was a good dude we hung out for a
little bit he had actually had a
television show uh him and his wife and
stuff and then I'm not sure but he was a
great I mean listen man aside from all
the people that he knew in Vegas which
also the Las Vegas country club was in a
casino
and it still looks the same way when
you're playing you could say oh this is
where the plane landed on the chasing
the and um
it stays the same way so it hasn't
changed much stay the same way but as
things change like the Mirage got bought
by by the Hard Rock Cafe and I performed
the Mirage for years and then now
they're gonna make it a hard rock I
believe with a guitar Hotel so there
won't be anything going on there for
like five years but when it opens the
Mirage had had the thing of the fire or
the white tigers yeah yeah that that's
like turn that page in history they're
gonna have a [ __ ] guitar Hotel on the
Sunset Strip and that'll just lead to
the next phase of how big can we make
these places then yeah wow
um bossy Siegel lost his eyes
for seven hundred thousand dollars he
was over and they said [ __ ] the kill
this guy this is some [ __ ] yeah this
guy's wasting our money for for 700 000
billions and hundreds of billions of
dollars yeah billions trillions of
dollars through Las Vegas yeah so that's
it all started right it all started
somewhere yeah
and in Comedians and and in uh Vegas in
places where they had uh shows and music
they would be you know bands which would
play and guys would you know Joe Montana
was in a band in Chicago and
what do you say oh he said
they played all the standards and then
there was a band that was playing their
own [ __ ] and they got fired and then
they called Joe Montana's band because
we'll be right over there they have all
wore the same suits and that band was
Chicago
wow so he's like that was [ __ ]
Chicago's like kind of players
I had to pay you guys for this [ __ ]
you're fired hey Joker You're The Five
Heartbeats kid over here Five Heartbeats
yeah yeah they come over there they're
in their big out of the [ __ ] same
haircut
they [ __ ] play forever but it was it
was Chicago the band there should be a
podcast that got pulled in or got fired
Chicago got fired and Joe Montana's band
were playing their own there should be a
podcast on all the guys that did that
like these four guys from Liverpool
enough I'm sorry listen to this cat
music
Talent the guy that got how about the
drummer that got fired from uh The
Beatles Pete best oh man he was in The
Beatles that's tough have you seen the
uh we talked about this a little bit on
the on our show but the Metallica
podcast or the Metallica documentary
because they interviewed the guy that
played with them at the beginning oh wow
did he play with them when they you know
for like two years and they start
they've just blew up started
yeah some kind of monster it's on
Netflix but then you know he like talks
within the bass player quits and he
talks to them for the first time and
it's that kind of thing where's it's
like what you know what could have been
and now everywhere he goes he sees
Metallica he hears Metallica it's like
they're the biggest band in the world
yeah yeah because he made a mega Death
afterwards
they must stay in my head when I'm
watching so much people should have
watched so much porn because I don't
know any of these [ __ ] screwed you up I
I fascinated myself with Georgia I live
vicariously through you you know
everybody the only one you haven't known
thus far that I've known that I didn't
know but the queen that's the only one
you said you hadn't yeah you met the
queen no I didn't I'm at the queen
that's the only person
you you met the queen yep I have a
picture of me and the queen hang on Oh I
thought you said you never I knew it
might come up
so I said um
I met the Dalai Lama there's a big
difference
that's awesome you know you know that
right
I'll show you the picture yes that's
cool you met the Dalai Lama yeah keep
listening to the show uh we're gonna
make a master list are we most
impressive people that I'm I'm satisfied
with meeting you and George
I mean I hosted cable game shows that's
pretty much on par with the Dalai Lama I
must have met electric no way
dude that is awesome yeah yeah holding
hands making all kinds of plans that's
awesome I saw him speak but I didn't get
to meet him you did meet the queen I
thought I asked you last week I met the
queen let me find it let me open up the
queen folder
you know pictures of me and the queen
any of the Royals that's the only yeah I
had my question that he didn't know
Royal folder ah
got him
there's a queen right there
right before he went put his [ __ ]
Tacony
yeah he actually came in the room faster
you had a Band-Aid
that
I bet the real queen though oh
Mr Elton John Sir Elton John sir sorry
that last picture was saying I believe
it's a mirage
oh cool you know what if you believe
that don't ask me why I have a picture
of Anthony Anderson t-shirt list
these things happen you know you don't
know how strong those pills are when
they come right out of the park I'm not
judging what you do in your own time
John do you know what I mean how a man
conducts himself I mean how are we I
mean this is like God damn
right here
this is Sexual Healing
hey Anthony
gets changed and then he was a standard
for Marvin Gaye
you called me the [ __ ] queen look at
that it's a complicated
a separate podcast just be George Lopez
120 [ __ ] degrees
might be with him
uh I hope he's like just in like stars
and stripes underwear underneath that
like that's all yeah more than likely so
so oh go ahead are we past Scientology
yeah
because I've been told that they like
follow up with you relentlessly yeah
once you get it's like the mob or any
cult so it's it's and uh
alleged alleged yeah alleged
um they uh but they have an agenda yeah
so they came after you for a while and
what's the agenda to get people to do
[ __ ] for nothing well it's it's like any
alleged
what's your personal opinion not after
fat people I can tell you that nobody's
contacted me
hang on a second
we can make a change
that's a good deal all you have to do
they just walk in
Black pass in a white shirt
what about Momo
if you don't have an extension
ah hey I'll tell him thanks
I haven't seen this patient
I want to see the Scientology tortoria
that's right I know same I would go away
it's probably going to go
that I want to check number three
is that when somebody calls still there
cool yeah all right thank you right yeah
I haven't done it in a while that's
great that's gold oh yeah so where are
we now where are we and you know what
and it looks like we haven't missed a
beat I haven't seen you in I know in
[ __ ] years probably I know dude it's
been forever I think I ran in you at the
Super Bowl in San Diego in 2003 or
something like that yeah know that's
right yeah that's only about 20 years
the [ __ ] Tampa Bay area
when Gordon took the Playbook went to
coach Tampa and [ __ ] ran the same
time
say [ __ ] fight we got one first down
I remember the radio went like this
first down [ __ ] everything went that
way
and the worst problem with ABC so I
wanted to leave they go no the bus
leaves at six but [ __ ] it's 3 45. well
it's leaving at three minutes after the
game awful oh it's all right good game
if you're I mean it was good well it's a
blowout we want Super Bowl but Carlos
Santana played at halftime that was a
great halftime show great halftime show
it's sick I yeah I'm a Bears fan I just
remember I bet Tampa Bay in the over and
I made money that's what I'm doing oh
yeah so you gamble you gamble not
anymore I used to I used to you don't do
you gamble no
Blackjack that's it but but people bet
games man yeah I know crazy now minutes
and stuff oh yeah it's wild can you bet
on your phone and all that stuff like
fan FanDuel or all those things that's
all on the phone that's all that's the
whole MGM just started it's all to get
you on your phone betting there's a new
uh coming up in the new election or
whether you can
26 and 27. I don't think it's a good I
mean
I don't know man I don't think it's a
good idea because he knows your house in
your house how about that shop they'll
come take it right you can [ __ ] sit
there oh yeah and just he misses the
field goal then oh yeah yeah so we're
gonna need
to admitted it crosses during the
[ __ ] guys I told you they would be
here guys thank God I told you they
would be here it's wide right
oh crap uh we're gonna need you to sign
this this is I don't I don't you know do
they still break legs and things like
anything oh yeah I would imagine uh I
don't know if FanDuel does but
maybe FanDuel probably has some guys for
that just in case but they get the truth
but it's more you know what they get
their money first yeah you can't open uh
an account unless you put down your
credit card and all your information
yeah so they they have your money
already yes yeah this might mean the old
enforcers must be bummed out they're
like oh yeah they're out of the job I
can't break a guy's knees anymore yeah
make a screen on this phone though
the uh
um
and then what else did were you married
did you get married yes I've been
married and divorced no kids wow why did
uh um where did you meet your wife uh in
Brazil yeah and she was Brazilian oh
yeah I went online
we always have sorry it's a thing it's
contractual it's a thing
since I was 11 years old this year or
not probably not but no yeah yeah
Brazilian women and and yeah and where
did you guys meet in Brazil in Brazil
you were on vacation are you working I
was down there and I had a buddy that I
grew up with who uh
and they yeah they lived in manaus which
is in the Amazon which is hot and so I
went up there and I met her and I was
like Brazilian women was she the same
way she was like
was she into you oh yeah yeah she was
like
yeah it was it was uh you know take me
out of here
it's It's Brazil oh my God
it's I I I I I I see why the state
department is so strict on the Visas
because if they came up here they would
take this [ __ ] over like it would
nothing would get done all these
American men would just be like bye the
president yeah let me check again all
right all right
the Brazilian women like they just have
this femininity about them and it's like
oh you're so handsome and you're just
like like it's it's and how long were
you guys married we're together five
years and we're still friends it was
like it was too much it was like a whim
well she moved up here and it was like
you know I was
all pictures all running through his
head
it's at his balls
I would say any American man
if you're single you should at least go
to Brazil once that's what that's what
Uncle Graham will tell you and I'll tell
you if you ever get divorce go to
Thailand because you'll fit in over
there they'll rub your stomach and
they'll jack you off
ah at the airport
just don't take any [ __ ] candies huh
they do that at the Hyatt at the Hyatt
Lobby
oh man they'll put you at a pedestal
I've been in Thailand I want to go back
to Brazil Brazil let's go back to
Brazil's I I it was I loved I loved it
there I speak a little Portuguese now
and uh yeah I will say that uh there's a
there's a there's a woman who's in the
Blue Beetle very young a model actress
and um
she's incredibly beautiful and she's
Brazilian very well known in Brazil I
don't want to say her name but in Puerto
Rico which is you know on the way to
Brazil we would have to get covet tested
for the Blue Beetle and there were there
was a
a nurse that would come not much up here
blue scrubs
knocking the door open the door I
wouldn't even let her in you know just
kind of in the doorway do this and when
she turned around oh it's like the
biggest James and the Giant Peach that
[ __ ] Peach oh
you could see her ass from the front
you're like
a [ __ ] Cape why is it rounding off
over there and when she turned around
she had the perfect
ass
I'll tell you my wife and some of her
Brazilian friends so we you know we
lived in San I would check off of the
tank
oh I got another sample for you oh the
doctor said I need to keep this one
sorry ladies oh you know I mean I mean
gorgeous right and they're not ugly
they're not uh first of all forget about
ugly
no one in Brazil is unattractive even a
homeless dude with no teeth
you know great shape yeah
you connect the two pubes coming out of
it
oh the only Priscilla but I remember
they are an incredibly like if people
are I mean it's I don't know who listens
to this but around anywhere
they're the most attractive people in
the world I'm going to say they're very
yes it's and I remember we're at the
beach and my wife and her Brazilian
friends were making fun of American
women's bikinis like nice cute bikinis
they're like they cover too much they
they were like because in in Brazil it's
like yeah here it is check it out and
they were like laughing at these
American women who had nice cute bikinis
on laughing at them like they were like
swimsuits from the 1920s like right
because on the Brazilian side but they
don't have anything they have their
little thing like a little tortilla chip
right here with a little stream that's
it
you're fascinated they put the little
Bandit on you that's it a little circle
one right that's it that's it so when
you went out guys would look at her sure
here because you know it's like you take
somebody from Brazil and bring them out
here you know it's like um
Maryland The Munsters you know the hot
one and then the family's like look at
them you know so so uh because a
Brazilian hot chick in Southern
California
because there's beautiful women here
sure you have to go someplace to see
them kind of together to a club or
somewhere you know they're not going to
be anywhere go to a dry cleaner you're
not going to see anybody attracted with
a [ __ ] dry cleaner yeah
[ __ ] back I mean ah Farmers Miller's
Outpost that's now
quiz those the uh uh but I mean when you
bring somebody like that and they walk
in their features are different
their body type is different
and then if you think she's beautiful
walking by and you look like that then
you see your ass you're just like oh my
God and the way they carry themselves is
very they just kid they just walk in
with this just like and you're just like
they just even a really beautiful
American woman who walks in and knows
she's beautiful walks differently did
Brazilian we've just come in with this
just like and you're just like
yeah so so but but where did you get in
Brazil
I know we got married here were your mom
and dad here uh yeah were they happy you
were married to Brazilian yeah
my dad spoke three languages and so he
liked speaking he wanted her too
what do you speak he spoke what Spanish
Spanish English Spanish and German and
they also spoke
if everybody should speak now
but they are I mean your wedding your
wedding picture you guys you wore talks
you're the whole thing or that was a
little small little thing on the beach
she had a beautiful dress I wore a suit
um she you know and when you get married
you you so you did all you got on your
knee and you said I proposed her in
Brazil you were underneath which in
Brazil they go can you turn around
take a couple licks
around
bend over a little bit right I want to
spend it
I think we should spend the rest of our
house
until or at least till my [ __ ] eyes
cycle
I took that through his part so my
[ __ ] eyes can't see this but and then
so you you got a ring and everything was
that important too or the size of the
ring or of them she did that she didn't
she was like no that doesn't matter to
me she goes I just want a gold band you
know like
um yeah she was really cool and I and
yeah it was it was you know it didn't
work out for a lot of different reasons
but we're still friends she's really
cool person you guys are still friends
yeah yeah like when my father passed
away two years ago she we she did this
she called me and she said your dad was
so nice he he you know it was it was it
was really it's really it's not
disrespectful you know yeah
um
I don't think I've ever
seen anybody who's Latino has been
divorced that
can stand look at the side of the other
person
hi
I'll stand by that
is there a personal uh experience no
it's just the way they are they'll say
okay you go with your mom's I'll honk
Sunday you run out Sunday
right you see it right they're just sure
they just it's just a thing it could be
cultural maybe I think when you're not I
think when you're not used to opening up
or talking about issues Things become
fiery instead of saying you know can we
talk about this the way we you know I
even had a case where the lady was she
divorced her husband but she hooked up
with his cousin and every time he'd come
to pick up the kids
make out right in front of him no no it
stopped on a Sunday afternoon after
Super Bowl
I got there he hit him with a shot
you want to eat the [ __ ] you bammy shot
the police what do you remember I
remember heard the sound okay
or the wife he blew the guy away not her
no blew the guy away walked a block and
a half to the gas station until the gas
station attendant called the cops
I just killed my brother-in-law wow I
have I was up for murders it was it was
within less than a mile away from my
house I went down there had the crime
scene everything done before my partner
even got there hey here we are let's go
down went down are you in your [ __ ]
shorts or did you dress like a design no
I dressed like a detective and then we
got down there the guy copped out to the
whole thing got it all wrapped up in one
day but was he just like accepting that
he was gonna do time like take me oh
yeah he knew he knew he was just tired
of her doing this and his cousin doing
it in front of him wow this was it it
was Super Bowl Sunday I don't know if he
lost a bet no super sun is the the most
violent day uh in of all yeah but he did
it I got it done
easy case wow so do you think in a case
like that
um that
killing that guy and knowing that he's
dead
satisfied that guy so when he went to
prison he could say to himself
I'm here
but I that guy's not here exactly
there's no doubt in my mind there's a
thing there he was satisfied he accepted
it he did what he did [ __ ] it you ain't
gonna do that no more
wow I didn't care about his wife I
wonder if he still feels that way though
because I feel like after being in jail
for like a decade you might be like um
maybe I could have just talked to him do
you think we could talk to anybody from
Death Row like do you think they'll call
us this is a call from Soledad yeah you
think I I'd like to talk to somebody we
can hook that up I think that I think
that'd be an interesting especially if
if criminals are
you know revered let's say in this world
of crime documents and crime podcasts
and what's all that stuff that'd be a
first short podcast
uh I want to see if I've been watching a
lot of uh Chris Watts
from Colorado Junior Chris watches does
he do that that no he he almost hate to
say it
he murdered he murdered his family he
worked for an oil company in Colorado
and he he had led he's in prison he put
his kids in oil tanks oh yeah I remember
that documentary he denied it yeah
all he had to do is divorce his wife and
and he and then he killed his kid like
it was crazy like I mean
you know there's a Fascination but then
also he had a mistress that walked that
walked away free when she deleted
everything from her phone all the
messages all the pictures and then she
got interviewed by the police who they
would they never read her rights they
should have
and she's like I don't know why you guys
want that stuff like why why do you want
it like so it's like so it's not
important to this it's like [ __ ] you
were [ __ ] a dude that was married
that
and they said why did you delete all
stuff because he lied to me and if he
could lie to me about this what else
could he lie to me about it it's like
it's like if somebody told you that what
would you say he's like you know what
I'm gonna read you your I'm here I'm
gonna I'm gonna hold you
which I can't hold you for 72 hours I'm
gonna read you your rights
even Chris watch that dude
never asked for a lawyer
all he had to do they said are you be
willing to take a lie detector test he's
like sure
and all he had to say was I'd like to I
like to I'd like to speak to my lawyer
and they and the question stop
it would have been a different vibe
right yeah the question stopped they had
him in that room they were switching
them out they were doing this or wearing
them down and he he can I mean clearly
you could see he was nervous and all
that stuff but
it's it's fascinating to people that
that this guy I mean whatever I think is
because it you can't say it could be any
one of us because we're not going to do
that right but it's it's it happens
in a neighbor in a fabricated
neighborhood in Colorado in this woman
and also she was a mid-level marketing
person that sold that stuff that you
know you make no money right all your
all her friends blocked her all his
friends at work blocked her because
every time you talk to her she was
trying to sell you something to her life
so all that [ __ ] weighs on you
and then you just [ __ ] snap I think a
guy can right I think a guy can a person
not a guy a person can take so much so
much depending on your circumstances I
don't care let them do it just give me
the case and let's let's work so you
weren't you you never you couldn't ask a
guy after like why did you do it could
you
sure I could ask a guy white even if he
invoked
if you invoke this constitutional rights
that just means anything he says can't
can and will be used against him in the
court of law however if he were to take
the stand
you know in his own defense like some
suspects do does it has that ever worked
out it's never nobody's ever taken stand
in their own defense in any of my cases
but if they did like Richard he invoked
oh wow he invoked he invoked the Fifth
Amendment now he invoked his rights to
Miranda oh not to talk to us without an
attorney being present however you know
he caught the Night Stalker right yeah
he wanted to continue talking to us and
we saw you can ask questions we'll
answer them and we carried on a
conversation
judge Peter Smith
in the preliminary hearing said that we
had violated it was the biggest
violation of Miranda he had ever seen in
all his years on the bench he's full of
[ __ ]
because why'd he say it was it had he
didn't come without a legal well he it
was his legal opinion it was however
we couldn't use anything we obtained
from Richard during those talks we have
another baby we can give them against
him in a court of law
however if he took the stand
everything he told us after that Miranda
rights could be used against him in
rebuttal ah so so long as we didn't use
anything he told us in the case in Chief
we were good so the judge was wrong
but we didn't never use we never tried
to use anything we didn't use anything
but had he taken the stand then we would
have but a judge's opinion isn't the law
the law is the law the law and he
thought that you guys had Violet in his
opinion in his opinion so you challenged
him on the law because his opinion was I
think you guys went on the preliminary
hearing and we ended up convicting
Richard hell yeah judge Peter Smith up
yours yeah
judge Peter Smith of your out there
please come by the show and yeah let's
get it you're around there
yeah account number 73 million 479
000 Comet Asterix when Richard got a
little upset
there was a uh Deputy Marshal named
Deluca and Richard was always told you
can look forward don't turn around you
know you can't oh wow and so so so they
tell a defendant yeah you can't look at
the audience start you you have to stay
Richard and
the Marshall came over there and said
hey the Prima was a guy's name the Prima
came over and said hey turn around you
got to face forward and
he knocked the prima's hand off his
shoulder when he did that the Primo went
at him and grabbed him you know you
don't hit me well now we're in a fight
well you touched him so it's a [ __ ]
strike yeah no matter how hard it is
they drug
uh Richard out of the courtroom on the
chair on the they just drugged his ass
and now the judge ran off the bench he
was he was scared
they took him out
and it was all for not Richard was wrong
uh his assistant the who's your [ __ ]
remember do all this [ __ ] to chicks man
like dude he passes down yeah he's
creepy as [ __ ] his legal age yeah about
the attorneys the legal aid Richard uh
those two dudes were the Latino guys
they were Hernandez yeah we scum the
hernandai because there were two of them
uh they they had a uh paralegal working
with him I've never heard that on
Netflix he came over because he thought
they were gonna be he came over to jump
in and help Richard and I just looked at
him and I said
don't do it brother I've been waiting
for this moment oh wow don't do it
because if he if he started to move in
then he's mine and I wanted to kick his
ass in the worst way I really did wow
and he said no no no no it's how it put
his hands up said no it's all okay what
about he's so [ __ ] sat next to a man
[ __ ] the Richard The Night Stalker
you know so it was what is it what do
you feel like what because I I believe
you know that's the name I think you get
the energy off of stuff like I said I
got energy as a kid in DACA and the
Scientology and I get you get I
personally think you get energy off of
people what the hell kind of energy did
you get off by that of Richard Ramirez I
didn't get any energy at all but he had
magnetism you said that he was nothing
more than another human and when Brady
goes into a football game you know
Monday through Saturday Brady's a dad an
uncle a buddy he drinks he goes to the
bars does whatever that's just like me
but when it comes Sunday game time and
he starts putting on the pads he gets on
the field it's game time when I I was
with Richard
it didn't matter anything that had gone
on it was game time I went in that room
I knew I had a job to do he was nobody
different he ever say to you like you're
lucky I'm not out there I [ __ ] you up no
no you ever said like hey Rich you know
what try it man let's see what you got
no no no he never did he never did eat
you actually said that when you got when
he got caught that his whole [ __ ]
Enigma kind of went away right yeah like
he was out there killing people he was I
mean it was
if this is who I am when he got caught
it was like the balloon the air got out
of the exactly
uh so and and he was probably one of the
most articulate murders I've ever
interviewed he was he was good he he
don't
I was good at my game
he was good at his game I was better at
my game that's all it was hell yeah wow
love that
that's all it was I have what might be a
boring question but I'll ask it anyways
and you guys can see Joseph and you've
been sitting there for an hour and a
half you're gonna ask a [ __ ] boring
question
might be boring I want to give that as a
warning just the joke knock out you're
talking this [ __ ] like
[ __ ] on his shirt the judge that was
a piece of [ __ ] would you say his name
was uh Peter Smith Peter Smith I've I've
heard uh various tales about Judges
being awful and to me watching I'm
always like why why isn't there somebody
that can reprimand the judge the judge
feels like this weird Emperor position
and there's so many [ __ ] judges and it
feels like no one can do anything about
it and they just have a job forever it
didn't matter he kept the legal grind
going oh everything was good
so he didn't throw anything out and then
the final judge in trial was a guy by
the name of Judge Michael Tynan who was
great oh there's there's a final judge
it sounds like that's the preliminary
hearing the final judge was Michael
Tynan thank God good man wait a minute
okay go ahead so so what were you saying
I would just saying no what are you
saying about uh that is that judge still
alive that's just not not alive I have
no idea whether Peter Smith is still
alive Michael Tynan is still alive and
he's the best what's up Michael you're
the man is is Ramirez still alive or he
get the chair no he no he died uh June
7th 2013. wow it was a it was a day that
my grandson graduated from junior he has
some respect and I'd say with a smile on
your face yeah
I'm a [ __ ]
I don't have to worry about appeals
anymore he's been adjudicated he's done
now he has to meet his maker not another
appearance
oh hi
hey who's there ah this is George Lopez
Ramirez calling from him and I think he
said
hey
let's go there this is Curtis antenna
can I talk okay here Richard hello hi is
the other is Richard Ramirez
how's your heart how's your liver
thank you for calling in Mr Amira so we
really appreciate you calling the show
um if if you could have one piece of
memorabilia from The Night Stalker case
would it be his imprints of his teeth
would it be
a pentagram that he drew on that desk
would it be the two Villages that opened
their legs as he walked by
e
he said that this dude had so much
yeah [ __ ] that goes live
sometimes he said that he that Richard
Ramirez had so much Swagger that sure
there's people there's women that might
be
uh they're all kind of dumpy you know
like me dumpy kind of half overweight
you know they look like they might have
been athletic at one point not as much
facial hair as I do but they're the ones
that that that right guys in prison and
say I'll suck your dick through the
glass
off
it makes me wish I was in prison
listen you just say you just save your
cigarettes buddy because I'm going in
there you can buy me for an Almond Joy
so so
um that's all I want Life as a girl to
say I was such a dick to the glasses
you know what I'll suck it so hard I'll
make it go back to being sad
sorry about that this is just a
different thing and I hope that NBC
doesn't watch this
we got to do you want to ask Gail a
question
we're doing the podcast man where you at
dude this dude's wearing the [ __ ] that
Graham would wear out there in Chicago
foreign
I'll follow you man we'll talk to you
later on because if you're listening and
George gives you a chance to ask a
question you better bring we did a thing
versus hub no no
you guys are against each other
well I guess it's the same thing because
we're like who's this dude uh what's
what's your name though what's your name
though
Jason what's your podcast about
this is Graham Elwood how you doing
uh Gil cut the Night Stalker
would you Ramirez
did you see that too cool cool I like
how he said that like oh cool this guy
doesn't wear a [ __ ] shirt you'll cut
the Night Stalker yeah he goes cool cool
he doesn't know the Night Stalker is man
I'm Ethan how's it going man
uh everything's cool I just started
going live again on this account so oh
yeah why what happened to the other
account yeah good night all right there
all right hey we're not saying that we
don't like that guys my Instagram
that was beautiful it was beautiful go
live again wait a minute what was I
doing when he had no question all of us
at the same time went all right okay
okay
Jason
um I mean I had uh questions for you
Graham if I can ask them sure I mean you
are filming a special very soon how long
have you been preparing to film I've
been that's something
years a month
I was gonna shoot a special in April of
of 2020. okay
um and that got scrapped and it was very
I started being about four five five six
years I started being more of a
political comic talking kind of like
Carlin how the whole system's broken
right sure and then pandemic came
everything got scrapped so you know I
didn't perform for 16 months like most
comics and then a little about 15 months
ago I started performing again and I
just started writing and I've been
working on it for about a year some of
it was older a lot of it's newer and uh
I'm shooting I like it yeah I'm shooting
at October 26 in Chicago oh yeah tour
dates at Grandma oh where where uh
Zanies the original Zanies in downtown
my pictures up there from when I was 22.
what what day is that do you want to go
over there Wednesday October 26th hell
yeah and then I got am I working a bunch
of dates leading up to it I'm doing New
York City the 18th Madison the October
20th Detroit October 21st Cincinnati the
22nd and then I shoot the special in
Chicago right so where can where can we
put Graham's uh information so that
everybody can see it
we can put it on the show notes the
description we can say it right now
Graham elwood.com boom yeah that's it
everybody go check it out six six stuff
and you're doing political vigilante
yeah it's political yeah it's it's
that's my podcast political vigilante
and government secrets
um we actually have three shows in
Europe as well government secrets we're
doing Stockholm October 3rd Berlin
October are you going over there yeah
dude wow yeah that'd be good for you
pool pond I can probably be good for you
I was in Germany wow good I love
Caddyshack I could quote that whole
movie I was in Germany for a while for
six months you know oh will you okay so
check this out so so Not only was he a
star Detective and look like uh Mindy
from The Facts of Life
this isn't even my forte podcast I just
have a beer or two and
sit in an uncomfortable position and let
them fly so I can not take this I'm
sitting on my balls anymore
but but but this is just the freest form
of expression for me like you know I I
love it so so but also he was in Via he
went to Vietnam
and thank you for your service really
incredible everybody who served in the
armed forces men women everyone and the
and their families God bless them thank
you but also he had an issue he had it
not an issue he had he had a uh
well an encounter with someone that
not many people who are uh alive would
could say that they had this exchange
with someone
by my old Captain fifteen no no no the
guy at the restaurant in Germany oh yeah
a hair fostering I I had a I was there I
had they had sent me to Germany by
mistake because I had requested to go
back to Vietnam because I didn't like
what was going on in Georgia they still
had racism going on there and yeah I
couldn't go off base it was it was ugly
it's like what is Germany and I met
friends in in Germany I'd go to this one
little disco ticket was a guest house
uh and a disco text so the bottom was a
restaurant the top was a disco and it
was the smallest
legal sized town in Germany a place
called prix's start so I go I used to go
there all the other GIS would go where
all the [ __ ] were I met a German uh an
army buddy him and his wife were there
so he used to go to this little town
over here where there weren't a bunch of
GI I started going
all of a sudden one night I meet hair
fosterling The Interpreter the waitress
comes up and she says he wants to talk
to you he said down right in front of me
he says
looking at me eye to eye through The
Interpreter he says I want you to know I
was a former SS Trooper oh man and I
used to kill somebody
Behind Enemy Lines sometimes with a grot
what say you
what's a garato people that don't know
that's uh uh piece of uh
choir with two handles on each side and
they would pull it tight holy [ __ ] and
that was what strangled immediately
and he says so sometime at times with a
garage what say you
and I'm in his German place and I look
at him directly and we never lost eye
contact
I said I've just come back from Vietnam
where I have had to kill Vietnamese
people or Vietnamese people were trying
to kill me
I said I hope
all Vietnamese people don't hate me and
I know I don't hate all Vietnamese
people war is hell and there are no
absolutely no winners
you did what you had to do for your
country I did what I had to do he looked
at me and he says
he was very happy he stood up through
The Interpreter I had to stand up next
to him and he told everybody in the
guest house at that night and then disco
that I was his friend I was an American
if anybody didn't like it step on up one
at a time or all at once we would take
him on
and everybody started cheering so we
bought drinks for everybody in the house
and it was like giving me the key to the
city amen but then you followed him out
and he did he had a son-in he had a dog
how how physical because those you know
they were they were specimens right
there the SS uh what what what did he
look like he was a big man he was a big
man he well statured he I was six oh
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] the other I I was
six three you know we're the four two
other other 4-2 goals yeah so he he was
he was a tall man he was good well built
was he over was he taller than you no we
were about the same okay well built and
this is what 25 years after the war
maybe this yeah this was in
1969. wow so he would have been maybe uh
20 years after the war yeah and so he he
just I I learned he had a daughter that
was married to a lieutenant in the
United States Army who would never step
foot in his house yeah of course because
as his son-in-law had never been to war
nor did he understand anything about war
nor did he understand why the man did
what he did yet I
did understand War understood the
meaning why we did what we did and so it
was like giving me the key to the city
uh but you know what I'm I'm not
condoning we would never but I think it
meant a lot to him you could say right
you know that somebody listened to what
he had to say sure and didn't say get
the [ __ ] out of here get away from me I
don't want to see you disgusting right
he had a story to tell he told a story
and then he asked you
are you cool with it yeah and you said
hey I work with I'm in the government
where I had to do this how to do that
and he said that's good my friend that
was it I understand
it was it was a beautiful uh and I could
do no wrong in the little town ever
since then the guy was good to me that's
an amazing experience and it is true
like I I don't know obviously hang on a
second I got a call coming in from oh my
God they're wearing a schnitzel
headquarters
getting a lot of phone calls today I'll
tell them you are uh you can't go to a
dream like like the like The Gambler you
can't go to the winner I'll tell you
something you're at the open one at Sea
you're not allowed to tell you something
else about you are banned from even even
saying that if your circumcised you have
a German Helmet you're banned from the
same age
oh
oh
okay I actually told me not to say the
thing about the German Helmet
I guess he's not alive they have a life
but but I'll tell you something about
wiener schnitzel when you're in Germany
Wienerschnitzel is veal yeah
wait wait like hot dogs out here wait a
minute
schnitzel we change the team weiner yeah
wiener schnitzel I didn't know that yeah
you will [ __ ] Halloween candy out from
your second [ __ ] Halloween
wiener schnitzel mitz peoples that's
veal breaded veal with mushrooms yeah
and you put sometimes you put some lemon
on it I love that when I was a little
kid oh and then when I got older and
they're like you know that's baby cows
and I was like oh that's horrifying oh
no for stock hour now this leave me
alone
God damn
how about this jacket the black you know
black and white print you like it yeah
I'm glass
uh Vine bitter a glass of wine please
and each I love you learn how to say
that [ __ ] in Germany
yes oh God bless you God bless her uh
how's she doing with your dad tonight I
mean they were divorced but still a
person you know my my dad was 85 he died
two years ago he lived a good life man
you know he helped put four kids through
college he was a you know either from HD
spoke three languages you guys got along
and everything right
for the most part I'm a comedian so yeah
I'm sure he didn't yeah was it he was
okay with me being before but you know
most comedians our home lives weren't
right perfect so you you agree with that
there has to be something that makes
somebody go to look for Acceptance in
strangers yeah I think I I mean are
there Comics who had really nice
childhoods and they were just inherently
funny sure I think maybe Jerry Seinfeld
might be something like that but I think
Mario joiners yep I mean but I think a
lot of it comes out of pain I think a
lot of it comes out of something that
happened or crazy trauma abuse and and
there's waste you know you can go
directly is it because if you throw you
in your room and you turn the TV on and
something makes you laugh you're you're
immediately it's like uh it's like a
blanket or something right right it's
that I think and also
I was the youngest of four my dad you
know drank and could be a rager and
comedy got you out of some jams you know
when you're a kid if you're funny you
got out of jams you know you learned
that and so your father was a professor
which probably wasn't afraid to pull a
few back no not at all went home was
probably the least interesting part of
his day let's say
he's at school he's teaching he's fun
goes home and then a day the life hits
him he's like well why are you why are
you you know just it's over with I think
right yeah I think so and also too like
he's coming home I mean this is the 70s
so my mom didn't work so there's four
kids and a wife so you work all day and
then you come home and I mean I was back
in the day where you know my mom would
say wait till your father gets home
right you know and you ever see that
cartoon it was awesome I hated that I
used to tell me what do you mean wait
till I get home you're over 21. did you
ever see the cartoon with your father
gets homes no no man dude it was awesome
man it was a cartoon man what was the
name of it call wait till your father
gets home you never saw that no you're
probably in Vietnam at that time I had a
problem
so
was he I mean you and then you're a kid
so you don't know if somebody's blacked
out you know they're saying some things
that are mean they're treating your
brothers mean they're treating your
mommy and you're like you don't know
anything about it this [ __ ] is
not going to remember any of this in the
morning there was you know it wasn't
the drinking wasn't that obvious in
terms of him like being blacked out but
it was just there was just some crazy
behavior yeah like that as I got older I
was I looked back and was like oh man
this was I think it was we had one of
those families like from the outside you
would have thought oh the L Woods
they're the fun the theatrical family
even the name though yes
and and I'd say it's like watching a
play where you think oh boy that that
cast must really get along and behind
the scenes
wasn't one of the Blues Brothers named
Elwood yeah Elwood and not only the
Jetsons were the Elwoods oh really yeah
that's right Elroy Elroy Elroy that's
close to Elwood yeah
did you ever watch The Tonight Show did
you ever want to be on The Tonight Show
when I was a little kid so I started
watching The Tonight Show
um you know and uh all the stand-up
shows I mean so what year was that that
you were watching The Tonight Show
probably 77-78 through through the 80s
and 90s yeah so I love Johnny Carson I
mean I fell in love with all those old
old school Comics Johnny Carson was
people that don't know oh
because nobody keeps their job that long
for one right that Johnny Carson David
Letterman
um
I said Letterman yes Carson also Gary
Shanley was very good on The Tonight
Show God Rest his soul he was very funny
and I think if
I think Gary shanling to me should have
been the pick I know Letterman wanted
Letterman would have been great but also
Gary Shanley was more like Johnny Carson
than Jay Leno was how about Jay Leno did
the first Tonight Show without Johnny
never mentioned Johnny at all in the
[ __ ] show really yeah yeah I didn't
know that I mean I don't like Jay Leno
he don't like me but whatever transpired
in our personal relationship any
comedian who grew up watching Johnny
including him should be [ __ ]
embarrassed that he did not mention I
don't know who gave you her advice but
to not mention the guy who created the
form of Dick habit of course you know uh
uh uh Jack Parr but you go and inherit
the Tonight Show and your first show you
don't mention Johnny Carson
it it it's it's awful man and I don't
think people especially younger Comics
today don't understand what the Tonight
Show there was three channels yes and
Carson dominated that time slot every
night incredible exactly and there's
there's no other moment and and you
watch that documentary where you hear
people like Seinfeld and stuff talk one
guy he called you to the couch after
your set that was it you were made you
were made I mean you your show business
career just took off and and there's no
other moment that's that was that big
yes people are saying now it's coming on
George Lopez
okay so so tell everybody again without
any ruption are we gonna find you social
media is where it's go to grandma.com
I'm at Grandma what on all social media
you get all my tour dates well October
tour Europe and the Midwest and then
shooting the special October 26th in
Chicago come out to a show follow me
it'd be great to see everything this
guy's great he's funny he's been
incredible his whole career and uh do
yourself a favor thank you guys uh and
go and see him